passé au deuxième sujet puisque on vous
parlait hier de l'ex boxeur al
christophe dettinger soupçonné d'avoir
agressé deux gendarmes ont dit
soupçonner d'avoir agressé deux
gendarmes à paris lors de la
manifestation des gilet jaune le samedi
5 janvier une cagnotte de soutien avait
été créé dès lundi afin de lui venir en
aide
hier et on ira rencontrer un très gros
succès puisque ya eu plus de 120000
euros en quelques heures
sauf que ce mardi 138 d'ailleurs litchi
la plateforme en ligne de collecte de
dons a annoncé qu'elle clôturait la
cagnotte
regardez on vous a résumé l'histoire
vous allez nous dire si vous êtes
d'accord avec la décision ultime parce
que au départ il disait en fait qu' ils
doivent accueillir toutes les cagnottes
voilà c'était leur position au départ et
ils ont changé de position pour ravir
samedi dernier avait lieu le huitième
acte de mobilisation des gilets jaunes
dans toute la france parmi les temps
forts ces images chocs d'un homme boxant
à crs sur un pont de paris qui ont fait
le tour d'internet et qui n'ont pas
manqué d'indigner de nombreux
internautes quand d'autres c'est lui au
contraire cette agression envers les
forces de l'ordre depuis l'homme a été
identifié par les autorités il s'agit de
christophe dettinger ancien boxeur
professionnel
un individu soutenu par certains gilet
jaune la preuve avec cette cagnotte en
soutien aux boxeurs relancer sur le site
de collecte d'argent litchi au total
plus de huit mille donateurs ont
participé à cette quête et cent vingt
mille euros ont été récoltés dans le
descriptif de la page de soutien on peut
lire les mots suivants me souhaitant
soutenir sa famille et lui montrer la
solidarité du peuple des gilets jaunes
du vrai peuple français
une initiative qui n'a pas du tout plu à
marlène scapa la secrétaire d'état en
charge de la lutte contre les
discriminations un rendez vous compte à
quel degré de haine nous en sommes
arrivés dans le débat public
cette cagnotte elle est honteuse de son
côté le site litchi a décidé de clôturer
la cagnotte et a précisé qu'il
veillerait à ce que l'argent récolté ne
soit utilisée que dans le cadre de la
défense judiciaire de christophe
dettinger alors selon vous leetchi at il
bien fait de clôturer la cagnotte du
boxeur
alors je voudrais avoir l'avis de yves
lefebvre vous êtes secrétaire général de
l' unité police fo vous pour vous bien
sur vos tombes ou penser que oui car
benny mémère merci oui yves tout
simplement les chinois déjà pas dû
ouvrir cette cagnotte
déjà premiers points à 2 c sans
reprendre les propos de chiapa mais
c'est une incitation quand même sinon un
cautionnement a cassé sinon même a tenté
de tuer du policier ou du gendarme mais
entendons-nous bien
lecce a clôturé la cagnotte
sauf erreur de ma part s'il avait
atteint un certain niveau
deux versants il est d'ailleurs prévu
une déclinaison d'un communiqué de
presse ce soir de litchi qui dit on va
reverser la somme
et si toute la somme n'est pas utilisé
pour payer les frais d'avocat du fait
qu'on appelle communément le boxer la
balle et les donateurs seront dirait
remboursés de leurs dons ce chaque don
est identifié non c'est proprement
parler scandaleux c'est une honte c'est
une honte on cautionne aujourd'hui dans
un état de droit comme le nôtre il est
encore jeune à travers ça le fait
qu'aujourd'hui on puisse frapper un flic
et qui pesait un flic à terre alors son
lapin sûr on ne cautionne pas du tout
non mais dans la plupart des spectateurs
ne concerne pas qu'est ce que vous
pensez
si l'on vous du commandant qui a eu un
dream box et le gilet jaune
comment andrieu il ya une enquête en
cours et une enquête on l'a roué enquête
on court aussi pour le boxeur oui j'ai
pas lu le boxeur sont pas dire que le
boxeur lui a reconnu les faits à travers
ces vitesses assez bien sûr oui voila
j'ai frappé j'ai des pseudos agressé
avant j'ai lu maire de prendre le gaz
lacrymogènes et j'ai frappé l'île
d'imagés fratrie non leurs causes sont
pas du tout senti mes larmes on n'est
rien on met en quête bien évidemment
faux ou pas vous et en l'occurrence mai
andrieu le commandant driant commissaire
divisionnaire andrieu il ya une enquête
en cours de l'igpn fida saisie du préfet
saisine du préfet du var
l enquête déterminera effectivement si
dans un premier temps il ya des
violences légitime ce la police a le
droit de la violence légitime par un
accord par délégation de l'état ou si ce
sont des blanches illégitime et auquel
cas il sera bien évidemment sanctionné
et voire même condamné par une
juridiction compétente d'accord alors
que c'est simple tout ça vous êtes gilet
jaune
jean-claude c1
c'est un garçon voilà c'est un amour de
mec voilà vous quand vous avez vu les
images de deux garçons vrai qu'on
surnomme le boxeur qu'est-ce que vous
êtes dit or il ya deux vidéos
oui il ya la vidéo où on le voit on la
deuxième vidéo où on en fait on voit un
gendarme qui frappe une gilet jaune à
coups de matraque où il arrive par
derrière
il prend le gendarme il lui fait une
balayette et là et en fait ils à se
battre de de pas mal de coups c'est donc
là je suis un quinze jours d'itt et est
d'ailleurs celui mais là je cautionne
pas ce que le gendarme la gilet jaune
elle avait rien fait il est arrivé il y
est allé à coups de matraque
donc là je cautionne maintenant de
cautionner le sur le pot là je ne
cautionne pas mais la deuxième vidéo
jeux la cautionne allemand la cagnotte
bien évidemment que je la cautionne ou
alors vous vous dites que il est
scandalisé par la fermeture de la
cagnotte
je suis alors dans la mesure où la somme
a été atteinte
bon je pense que vu l'avocat qui est
qu'il va avoir c'est vrai que 130 mille
euros c'est quand même assez énorme
voilà voilà voilà donc je pense que vous
étiez pour cette cagnotte c'est à moi
j'étais pour cette cagnotte quoi c'est
normal qu'il ait un avocat pour pouvoir
se défendre
je donne un exemple c'est on prend
l'exemple du commandant de rieux lui par
contre dans la parano personnes
s'offusque que qui viennent frapper des
gens même devant les caméras et au
contraire il va avoir la légion
d'honneur donc c'est quelque chose
certaines vidéos qui tournent d'ailleurs
sur sur les réseaux où on voit des
fonctionnaires de police frapper au sol
il se mettra plusieurs a frappé à coups
de matraque à coup de pompes des gilets
jaunes qui sont au sol sa personne ces
personnes sans nous faisons quand on
voit la violence quand ils tirent au
niveau du visage avec les flash-ball sa
personne son opus apparemment c'est
normal puisque l'état a le droit a le
droit de riposter jean-claude juste toi
tu cautionnes la cagnotte lui qui parce
que tu dis il a le droit d'être d'être
défendu la barotte défendu comme la
coiffure
donc c'était n'importe où à ce que dit
jean claude parce qu'il ya plein de
personnes aussi dit les jeunes qui
pensent comme lui et qui ont veillé
décidé de le boxeur alors gilles
j'entends ce que dit jean claude mais je
suis en parfait désaccord parce que
cette cagnotte là c'est pas une somme
pour qu'ils se défendent tout homme a le
droit d'être défendu
c'est devenu un symbole et effectivement
elle a pris le symbole de on donne de
l'argent à quelqu'un qui a tapé un
représentant des forces de l'ordre dans
l'exercice de son boulot et ça ça passe
pas moi je pense que vous auriez dû vous
désolidariser de cette action est de
cette cagnotte
c'est une fausse bonne idée ça va se
retourner contre les gilets jaunes de
mon point de vue il veut yves lefebvre
oui monsieur journaleux offert les
propos de monsieur de jean-claude
vraiment parler scandaleux c'est ne vous
étonnez pas un moment donné que votre
mouvement en soit complètement
décribiliser vous perdez toute notion
aujourd'hui du revendicatif saint
naturelle légitime que vous aviez au
départ aujourd'hui vous êtes parti non
pas sur une fronde contre le
gouvernement aujourd'hui votre angle
d'attaqué
ce sont les forces de l'ordre non vous
ai dit le commandant divisionnaire
andrieu s'il a commis des fautes que l'
enquête déterminera peut-être qu'il n'a
pas commis peut-être que l'on a commis
l'enquêté le déterminera
il sera sanctionné et voire même bien
évidemment condamné
là vous appelez vous appeler ce nouveau
appelé hier monsieur vous me rappeler
les propos de jean-luc mélenchon qui
lisse et un punch il a entre sommes un
peu raccord vos propos monsieur je vous
le dis malgré les propos j'irai quand on
souhaite on a pu avoir dans les
coulisses pour propos là sur quasiment
appel à des actes criminels
ce que vous dites là c'est scandaleux
monsieur scandaleux attendent au petit
but quel patron de la chaîne qui lui qui
m'a appelé pendant l'émission tu sais
pas ce qu'il en soit s'il veut me
rappelait il francs capitaux par mot clé
est une urgence
je vous dirais jean-claude qu'est ce que
vous allez c'est pas un à bâbord loin de
là c'est je crois que c'est vraiment un
non violent mais depuis je ne mets pas
du tout tout le monde tous les
fonctionnaires de police dans le dans le
même sac
maintenant quand vous voyez ce qui s'est
passé hier avec la la la marche des
femmes gilet jaune
vous trouvez normal qu'elle soit n'a
c'est qu'elle soit obligé d'uriner non
mais justement et que pour certaines on
les mettre dans une rue et que certains
fonctionnaires de police les ont
tabassés parce que là il ya des plaintes
contre la police qui vont qui sont
déposés par m e william bourdon a
justement à l'encontre de la police
j'aimerais vraiment qu'on reste sur
cette histoire de gagnac litchi vous
donc vous comprenez pas qu'on puisse
arrêter cette cagnotte c'est ce que vous
dites
la cagnotte dont elle a atteint 130
mille euros non mais si l'on vous êtes
complètement solidaire du boxeur en fait
à l'auberge solidaire en partie oui
parce que moi je me réfère à la la la
deuxième vidéo si vous l'avez vous
pouvez la montée où justement il défend
une femme gilet jaune est là pour moi
c'est de la légitime défense
d'accord alors on va voir on va pas
pouvoir voilà autant tout le monde dont
michel non non je vais juste dire
qu'évidemment claque ton retour ne
dénoncent-ils inadmissible à face contre
le sol boxeur s'en est pris à cet agent
et forces de l'ordre c'est inadmissible
mais je pense que ce qui est plus grave
plus symbolique c'est que je pense que
la plupart des gens qui ont qui ont
financé cette keynote c'était pas un
appel une approbation la violence mais
ces genres comme on est dans un
soulèvement qui est pratiquement
populaire il ya la volonté de boules à
répondre coup pour coup genre on appris
dans le caca momond soutien c'est comme
dans une révolution tout de suite un
rapport de force qui s'installe et à un
coup porté on reporte on reporte un
autre coup et cette cagnotte
l'importance de la canette voulait dire
genre vous nous aurez pas comme ça on va
continuer plus simple alors bon on va en
se rompant ses téléspectateurs tient
litchi a bien fait de clôturer la cave
du boxeur et ben oui à 59 % de non à 41%
c'est s'est pas écrasé c'est pas
écrasant pour leur écrasant pour le oui
et beaucoup de gens pensent comme eux
comme comme jean-claude je voudrais vous
remercier jean trudelle de nous voir et
yves d'avoir voix l'a défendue au point
de vue merci merci mais non merci mon
jeu court
[Applaudissements]